Look at that. You see that? That's the Sun but you can barely see it. You know why?
Clouds. Very clearly, clouds are blocking out the Sun and the Sun as I always say is our only source of life in this universe.
Without the Sun, we're nothing. Without the sun, we won't go anywhere. Without the sun,
we can't live. We need to find a way to harness the power of the sun. Not let it go to waste hidden behind clouds-
That's not benefiting anybody.
You know after Halloween, bloodstains don't look so good. They're kind of suspicious, probably cause some problems.
I'd like to think that this is our van so, you helping out means a lot to me.
...but you could help out faster.
*whiny Mark* What have you done now? It's 'Bo,' that's fine, 'Bo,' it's-it's less scary. People go like, oh 'Bo!'
I know Bo, everybody know Bo, who don't know Bo?
*Mark grunting*
Alright. There we go. Get in!
Hey, how's it going?
What are you doing? Hop up here get over here get up
Up! Up up up up up up!
Okay never mind then. Alright Chica you went to your favorite.
I understand how it goes.
Riddle me this; how does the Sun allow us to power a fridge? The Sun, burning hot, very heated
Extremely temperature high. Let's get a reading on that Sun.
*beep*
That's the current temperature of the Sun.
(whispered) That doesn't make any fucking sense.
*another beep*
This should be working right? I'm not an idiot.
Okay, just trust me when I say the Sun is very hot okay?
The Sun is a burning ball of gas, that's currently fusing hydrogen to be able to create energy...
...and we can harness that energy
Up on this bad boy up here. oh
up-
On the other side of this bad boy over here
We've got the space necessary to be able to put on...
Say it with me!
Soolaaar Paaanells
You didn't say it with me.
The sun *little 'ticks' as he angrily hits the white board*
Shooooots its rays.
These are the same DNA blasting rays that it always gets.
If I was here standing in front of it...
I would be very much dead.
Dead, dead, dead!
But- we can allow it... *Chica pants loudly over Mark*
CHICA
Shhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
*quiet Chica*
The sun's rays will be smashing into *Hits board*  this killing that dead, but not us because that'll be on the roof
We're in here all safe and can duty.
Okay?
So then we hook that up to what's called a So-lar Gen-er-a-tor.
And that's got big-ass batteries in it,
that's gonna be able to power everything we're gonna be able to power our TV, power our fridge, go on camping trips.
Do whatever we need to do, whenever we need to do it.
Make sense?
So what do we need to do?
Blam
Okay?
You're not gonna find a solar planel [panel] just laying on the side of the road.
So we gotta go...
get one.
From what's called a "store!"
So, get over here.
We gotta go!
Buckle up for safety!
*Mark laughs* Here we go! *sound effect of a man screaming  and glass breaks*
Bam! That place
Oh, shit, I can't leave Chica in the van...
Can you stay with Chica?
Keep her safe, okay?
I'll be right back. I'll get everything we need hop skip and jump no time at all.
Right? Cool. okay
Don't you dare go joyriding.
I know what you did last time.
I'm watching you.
*noises of Mark fumbling for door handle*
*door slam*
*Passenger door opening*
*door slamming*
*Chica panting*
*keys jingle*
*Keys turning, Car beeping, engine starting*
*loud obnoxious car ringing*
*putting car into gear*
*car door opens*
All right so, uh, *car starts obnoxiously ringing again* no luck on that one.
Weeeeeeeee *mark dragging out we with the car ringing*
We need to go to the Burbank location which is a bit farther away 'cause they actually have it in stock.
That's 45 minutes away.
That's a long drive, but we can do it right with the van anything is possible,
and we can go wherever the hell we need to go. Am I right people? Am I right people?
Of course I'm right. It's me we're talking about.
Mr. Ru-
Squirrel!
Hey, I'm king of you!
*Michael Scott NO sound effect*
Okay
We got another place. Hopefully they have it. If they don't I'm gonna get whatever they got.
But yoooouu-
Gotta stay in here.
Now I'm trusting you with this. Take care of Chica. No joyrides, okay? Watch out for squirrels. Okay, alright. I'll be back.
Bye Chica! I love you!
*kisses Chica*
(slurred) I love you. Bye, I love you!
(slurred) I love you!
*Places kiss on Chica's nose with a squeak toy sound*
*Yeah Yeah Yeah - Heads Will Roll (A-Trak remix) plays*
Why, uh...?
Why is the van turned the other way?
Hyuh- Oh God.
Alright, so we are successful what we have right here is we have.
um, really overpriced and, uh
Ridiculously under-powered solar panels, which aren't the big, bad boys that I want.
But I got them anyway because I needed to get something *hit* so I got these *hit* and that's what I got *Hits box more*
*sighs*
Blublublublublu
Bonk! But we don't have installed yet, and we got this big-ass
Thousand watt hour lithium-ion
Storage generator thing-a-ma-bobber with a lot of power and some good outlets
It's gonna make that TV and that fridge plus a game console once ever where *wild mark noises* were able to get that.
We're gonna be able to run it. Bing bong boom boom. Hey got you something too. Don't think I forgot about you
Got you this!
*glass shattering SFX*
It's a head lamp! You know, when it gets dark out!
I know you're afraid of the dark, so I thought, y'know, it'll be pretty cool. You open that up!
I'm gonna get it somewhere good. I still don't know why the car is magically turned around. Oh, thank you.
Yeah for returning it very safely, right?
Wait if I get to the top of that parking lot,
I'll be closer to the Sun and that means we're gonna have the optimal amount of Sun to be able to do what we need to do.
*Painful scrapping noises*
Ooh. I thinky thunkle we scraped.
Check and see what we got going on up there.
Still up there?
Eh.
*intense scraping and banging noises*
Maybe we're not gonna be able to get to the top of this roof. Maybe!
There's enough Sun on the ground level that we don't need to risk, uh,
losing that storage container.
*grunting and moaning* *Muffled Scraping and plastic denting*
Tasty.
There's the Sun. See? Not much Sun left but
We got some Sun and it's poking through the clouds, which means that we're gonna be able to take advantage of that.
What do we have here? Doodly doo. User guide? Pfft. Extended warranty? Blehlele. Warning?
Whoa!
Shoobity doobity.
*grunts of effort*
That is a big boy! So this bad boy,
Not only will it be able to power this fridge and that TV. It will also be able to power the game console
I wanted to get something that was more than what I needed. That way, I never have to worry about upgrading later except
I did the exact opposite with the solar panels because I got them because it's the only thing they had and I paid more than
I should've for what I didn't get. But this bad boy
I don't have any regrets about. I'd probably have regrets about it if it blows up
Because it's lithium-ion
That has a tendency to explode
Never exceed 30 volt input. Will cause damage to the unit and can- could cause injury or death. Do not chain panels in series
Doing so will cause damage to the unit and could cause...
Injury or death. If you're using multiple solar panels call our solar experts for safe set up procedures
Nah! We got to get this bad boy outside, and then we got to somehow string it inside not a hundred percent sure
how I'm...how am I...how, how am I?!
Wait... how do I get?
Okay, hand me that thing? So this could be dangerous, could explode, kill us all, or it'll be fine.
So, boin-
*explosion sound*
*explosion sound and rewind sound*
Your input
No...!
So, supposedly this thing has a solar intensity output.
These little lights here are for solar intensity so it's got a big ol' zero
Is it 'cause it's cloudy? What if I smile at it? People say I've got like a- a smile that could light up a room.
*panting*
*audible smiling* Anything? *continued panting*
*angry sounds*
Cock.
Okay, it's alright. You know why? Because this battery's already fully charged, and you know what else this battery has?
A car input. Solar may not work right now and frankly these solar panels aren't exactly what I wanted anyway
But this bad boys still a big old bad boy battery and this bad boy battery can charge up a whole world
I gotta take out Chica's bed for just a second, but don't worry Chica
I'm not evicting you, I swear!
Put that bad boy right in there and put this bad boy right in here. Where's my van. It's right here
Turn that bad boy on see this bad boy light on there plugged into here. We've got input.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Hey hey hey hey! Did you see that?
Yeah!
*squishy SFX during high five* *Squeaky toy SFX during fist bump*
Mother Nature can take another hit you know
Just for the time being it's still a big-ass battery and that big-ass battery is gonna be able to power
this fridge and this TV so watch and learn because
We've been waiting on this for a long time. Get in the van!
C'mon Chica get in here! So it's got two plugs right here, so first up TV. Blam.
*Bungee cord flinging* AHAHHAHHH
Yeah
Yeah, oh, yeah. Oh yeah moment of truth. What we've all been waiting for.
It's reading more power being drawn, so I'm thinking
I'm thinking
if we open this fridge up
It's not cold yet
But it's a lot. Oh my god. It smells so bad in there. Oh. Oh it smells like packaged death!
That's so awful. What do they have in there?
All that aside,
We've got everything that we need. All we need now is to celebrate.
Man this fridge may smell like death, but I bet it will keep these cans of squirt ice cold, baby.
Here's one for you, so thank you so much for all the help.
I mean we don't have the solar panels on the roof yet, but one step at a time
We got this fridge working. We got that working
We've got enough power going on to last us like through whatever we want to do
I could even like hook up my laptop to this bad boy
And who knows what I could do?
Maybe I could even figure out a way to live stream from this van and that'd be pretty cool, but that's for another day, so
Thanks again, and
I'll see you tomorrow
Buh-bye!